but in terms of the amount of units that
the trilogy had going at any given point
in different parts of new zealand
different call times different actors so
many different
crew members
is it overwhelming for you to to be
aware of the fact that this is such a
huge operation or do you treat it like
pete was doing which is a massive
independent film i treated it the way
pete did and also we were very fortunate
i mean each unit apart from barry
osborne we had these robust production
managers for every unit as you guys know
and robust ads so it really was an
unbelievably great team so i tried i
remember tried never to think about the
fact that we had seven units going if
you include like miniature unit and blue
screen unit and sort of gollum unit you
know like that i tried never to think
about it too much but then when we would
watch dailies if you guys ever did that
and of course it was on film yeah so no
there's no fast forwarding there's no
anything you watch and that could that
could that took two three hours could
you believe that pete did that yeah
all is filming and then sitting watching
sometimes
20 takes of the same thing
[Music]
with me and hold me tightly through the
night you're shining bright i'm your
voice the baby you're my pearl